tu es là s'en trouvera pas ça tombe bien
il faut qu'on discute enfin alliage
hommage là et ça pique tellement je peux
pas parler c'est un sujet de mes études
je veux être mais de 7 à 20 ans tu n'as
pas putté le ton pauvre père et puis
d'abord pourquoi faire soigner les gens
pas par ce serait très bien si tu allais
déjà jusqu'au parc un essai après le bac
je vais continuer à y aller tu me
fatigues
pourquoi tu es toujours en train de me
désobéir les lances d'études coûte cher
et en plus ça sans tête pour les hommes
tu trouveras un mari qui s'occupera de
torpeur d'ailleurs on est invité chez
mon patron je veux que tu vois son fils
un beau gentil garçon avec qui va
falloir d'heuliez dans liszt et pendant
que je priais tous les dieux de notre
planète pour qu'il me donne à nouveau
père bintou s'éclater dans sa matière
favorite le sait courage de tasses à
bâle
g
totor les dégâts trop bien le dire et le
roi du ziglibity aux personnes qui
savent où me placer ma fille m'avait dit
que j'allais te rencontrer dans ce
maquis de jeunes en tout cas merci de
m'inviter à caen c'est ma fille de temps
en temps c'est bien de se frotter à la
jeunesse cinq ans m
et si tu continues à tout courtier comme
ça qui va me tuer mais vous la faites
attention avec vos buzz pardon ya c'est
en tout cas ce qu est ce que tu t'es tu
profites ton meilleur ami même rien
copie on ne faisait que danser tout
comme toi d'ailleurs avec cette jeune
fille qui suivent aussi la fille de
quelqu'un je m'en fous tu devais revoir
bond espèce de caves à moi qu'à fans et
toi tu as peut-être quand on tue des
margouillats tu me suit en plus petit tu
vas voir